got my mom except that no so I loved the
movie Thank You great one of my favorite
things about it was the way that the two
storylines were we've done together what
was your first reaction when you saw the
script um that was one of the things I
loved as well as how he was taking us in
and out of like past and present and the
story and the reality and it seems sort
of impossible to do seamlessly and so of
course I wanted to figure out how Tom
intended to do it and he had such a
wonderful presentation and and such more
Terfel ideas about sound and light and
emotion kind of carrying us through and
so I was like let's do this it sounded
great and what was your favorite thing
about working with Tom Wood um you know
it was that he allowed he allowed scenes
to play out like even if he saw them
kind of going in a way he hadn't
envisioned he allowed them to sort of
take a journey in that direction to sort
of see what will come of it and
especially just I do a lot of reading
and a lot of time by myself so he
allowed for me to breathe just read
on-screen which we don't see very often
like long takes you know yeah and you've
always got two huge films out this yeah
yeah are you excited about award season
I mean in in the sense that I love that
I'm in films that are in the
conversation is wonderful you know
there's so many films that are worthy
that don't sort of get talked about and
so it's really nice that the films are
getting talked about and I'm really so
proud of both films and really enjoyed
the experience of making them so it's a
joy to get to to get to talk about it in
that way and that people are talking
about it so if it brings attention to
the film's I'm all for it your
characters season in the movie she talks
a lot about being a realist as opposed
to Edward who's a dreamer yeah in your
opinion I'm more I'm like what's your
favorite I mean what do you think it's
more important I think both are valid I
think we need both you know I think I
might have been a dreamer at some point
but some point life kind of got a hold
of me and I became very pragmatic I
think it's probably why I was so
attracted to that quality and my husband
because it's something that I find
it's just admirable to be able to kind
of have these ideals and yeah but I'm
definitely I don't say I say I'm
pragmatic yeah I'm pragmatic yeah and if
you could give one piece of advice to
your character in this what would it be
mm-hmm I mean I can be funny about it
and be like don't wear the dark red
lipstick but um I think I mean it's it's
funny because we see her when she's
younger and that's probably when I'd
want to give her the advice yeah yeah
trust your heart don't let your head get
in the way of your of your soul don't
let don't let don't let other people's
voices be louder than the voice of your
own heart yeah and in films while she is
compared to her mother and she actually
says like nothing says Laura Linney's
delivery of that line is like the best
line yeah is that who you agree with
that we all turn into our mothers yeah I
don't know if we all died did but I I
don't know if everybody does but I look
at my daughter and I think that all the
time when she's you know because she's
so striving for her own identity and she
does have such a unique and beautiful
identity that's so separate from mine
but she does have some things in common
and I'm just like okay I know how this
ends and you want to like help her
or stop her from making those mistakes
but you're just like there's no stopping
oh great thank you so much and very well
my coffee is kicked in I can totally
feel it it's just I like like that's
that I'm not sensitive to substances
that it's like coffee it's just like I
know right I know